i am addicted to my phone cause like my
head is getting distracted
action
[Music]
get your head in the game joseph i like
jk news how about you guys
get your head in the game you know which
game i'm talking about the game of news
the game of jay kane i'm just kidding
the game of
love well the game that this
couple here they really put their head
in the game
and they won the lottery you see joe
she's calling you a loser can you help
this team win please
yeah thank you so get your head in the
game you came
what game is this game [ __ ]
[ __ ] there you go
it's back all right so this couple named
emily and mark
from the uk they competed
in a reality tv show competition where
they would win
their own alaskan dream home
oh wow what they have an alaskan dream
home alaskan that's beautiful so these
people in the uk
yes competing for a dream home in alaska
yes
i want alaskan dream home against five
other couples
do you also from the uk i believe so do
you think it's the same kind of
weather and everything as the alaska
the uk do you think probably are they
same in the same area
do you think alaska is more north i
think alaska is more naturey
versus like the city of uk like the
cities of uk
you know what i mean i i'll put my money
on that
i don't know man i've been to the i've
been to the uk's and i've been outside
of london
and i have to say it's pretty natural
you missed it he said the cities
of the uk okay okay okay i'll give you
that not the townships he's playing a
little trouble i'm talking about [ __ ]
grizzly bears and stuff
did you see the grizzlies out there no i
saw rolling hills
so this is mark and he looks like a
grizzly bear himself
he looks cute so they are the winners of
this alaskan home right yeah but they're
not american
they're not so i'm actually gonna play
the trailer for
the reality show and then you guys can
get to meet there
it's one of the alaskan homes i've been
looking at
you've been looking at homes in alaska
well there's this builder i
like and they build homes like in utah
they look sick
well this one was built by the couple
who
who built it oh okay oh it's accustomed
to what they want
their design here
it's a [ __ ] tent here we go
wow that's beauty but it's like cold
alaska
in the heart of the wild could make the
dream where are they gonna get groceries
they grow their own [ __ ] i think
six couples wow each hoping for a new
start in alaska
have come to lay claim to the property
and transformed their lives wow
absolutely stunning
and the decision that you should take on
this property will be made by the
remarkable people who built it
interesting we've left our blood sweat
and tears in here believe you me
it's been a real labor of love whoa
pirate
years ago dwayne ossie and his wife
reena began building their dream home
but now with their children unable to
take it on
they are ready to pass on their legacy
to someone new their kids want to be in
the city
they're like [ __ ] this country [ __ ] but
it's time for a new chapter
we're looking for a couple to carry on
what we have started
yo that house looks brand new it's only
30 years old oh man
are they gonna be [ __ ] up and just
tear the whole thing down
what did everyone have an orgy in there
and kick them out no no
what else what else are you guessing uh
the bear came and then bit off the balls
and then they had the orgy with the bear
oh no close they kicked them out they
kicked out the couple like early like
oh you're getting the grandpa actually
has a eye under the ipad
that's the most [ __ ] up part about
this no trick joe
over the course of the four week
challenge yeah
the this couple they've chowed down on
bear meat stew
they plunged into freezing water and did
other challenges that's the alaskan
lifestyle i got an idea
they changed their mind they're not
giving it anymore what
oh why did you ruin i was gonna say that
they brought corona to the old people
oh no so what ended up happening the old
people changed their mind
well not the old people so the husband
yeah the the wife she ended up passing
after the challenge like after this or
this
uh couple emily and mark after they had
already won
uh the wife had passed and so this
couple they had been in contact with
the husband dwayne and so they were just
like
trying to coordinate they had they were
supposed to already have the property
in their possession but because of the
pandemic a lot of things
delayed and so they ended up keeping in
touch with dwayne
but it turns out that dwayne ended up
getting a new girlfriend
oh what the [ __ ] in alaska in alaska
maybe the show made made him so hot and
popular
but she's like that eye patch was just
no i thought it was going to be so
heartbroken that he's like i can't
i can't get rid of you [ __ ]
i couldn't wait not to get no new [ __ ]
yeah so he actually married the
girlfriend holy [ __ ]
he did this in a matter of months uh
maybe a year he also doesn't have much
time left
that's true i mean but still you gotta
move fast so rina died and
she died in may for after a heart
operation
got married in june and then the next
month that's when he began
a new relationship how is he even
finding people
to date in that [ __ ] forum that's
what i was wondering facebook dude
yeah you think they've been already
talking yeah probably
yeah so then on facebook is when where
dwayne announced that he's reclaiming
he said he wrote reclaiming my legacy my
home from
faux foreigners who do not care for my
wishes
so now the couple who won they are
claiming
that this new woman named ellie may
she is the one behind the the post and
she's also the one behind
the text conversation between the couple
and dwayne and it seems as though
she's the one that is trying to get
dwayne
back out of the deal not give over the
property and it seems like she's a shady
[ __ ] in all this
whoa drama right
[Music]
i mean if they could save up like a
hundred thousand dollars they could
probably have a property like that
well the thing is no the thing is it's
already there
they're already the owners they already
earned it fair and square so they signed
it
they had to win so then the old guy is
squatting pretty much it seems like
so i don't know what the current current
situation is but
that's as far as that has been reported
so the couple they said that they said
the text certainly used words i've never
seen dwayne use
you can almost imagine ellie mae banging
her fingers through the keyboard some of
her statements are so irrational
what if she killed him
and then she's just she has this
identity
and she wants to live there at that
point i'd be like keep the [ __ ] vat
[ __ ] bad vibes i don't want that [ __ ]
keep your [ __ ] house no but then if
you
kick her out then then then his ghost
will thank you
yeah because he's like oh thank god you
got it back dog like a house has a ghost
now
yeah then it'll like make sure like you
get fresh fish and like it's like your
only neighbor
yeah like a ghost well your roommate
like roommate the wife is gone too
oh yeah yeah but then but then oh
they'll be fighting because she's like
[ __ ] why did you [ __ ] do that to me
you son of a [ __ ] that's all crazy
though like one month later after his
wife passes he already moves on to a new
relationship i would let their spirits
just fight
i wouldn't want the property i'll sell
it it's a three-story home yeah but it's
alaska yeah and that's
bad vibes i'd rather i want good vibes
always let them haunt that house and
fight for the rest of their lives
technically she should want him to move
out of that house that they built
together
right if it's real love because she gold
digger yeah cause
i don't want the [ __ ] memories of
your old eggs and the memories that you
had there yeah i don't look at the
kitchen and know you better over there i
know
right with your eye patching [ __ ] you
have to move it to one side
yeah so now this couple is just dealing
with all this drama but they said
despite the turmoil they don't regret
agreeing to the reality competition they
said
we do it all again but this time not win
it so i'm like why would you do it all
again maybe it was fun
but then the the the problem is now
expecting to get something
right because if you were like oh we
lost isn't that a good adventure like
you're like oh that was great but then
now there's like all this extra [ __ ] you
know what's kind of messed up too that
they
the couple they were talking to dwayne
in order to
go over to alaska and then release the
wife's ashes
like they were gonna do it together and
then somehow
this new chick comes in and just [ __ ]
it all up
[Music]
women really men women it's shady people
pardon me he also chose her
yeah that's why i said man he's in love
he can't help who he falls in love with
how is he gonna fall in love in a month
love is love is
when you're old and horny yeah
and you're old and horny so wait wait is
it if it's a tv
show wasn't there some type of like
contract and like oh yeah so like i said
the couple they had already
like they already legally owned the
property
so it's just that this dude's like nah
you can't have it what
are you allowed to do at that point can
you call the marshals and be like
someone's on my property can you kick
them off yeah you mean randy that's his
house he goes not anymore
i think he just got to shoot the dude
and play oh i was aiming for a bear i
missed
yeah i thought it was the great white
bear eye patch beard
that's the scary part about areas that
are like
secluded like that you can actually just
kill somebody and nobody will know
yeah that's why i hate even going to
areas like that whenever like i even
like i'm driving down a street that
doesn't have a lot of like
lights and [ __ ] i'm like damn someone
could murder me right now yeah
i mean think about just right here in
norcal right in humboldt like
they call this area murder mountain i
saw a netflix documentary about it but
in that area people go missing
there's a big like weed industry out
there and then like people jack each
other
and it's a wormhole for another
dimension oh
yeah but it's also a high risk area
because there's no law enforcement
that's why they're scared of you why
would anyone even go over there then
because you know it's called you're
running business and then you're growing
and then like some people
you know they want to live that life
where you just like live on your own
property and
whatever's yeah i got a new house where
murder mountain yeah right
well that's a big deal too that's the
nickname murder mountain
yes yeah so like
in california you wouldn't imagine
somewhere
like that but it goes it's like it
happens and people go missing
and it's like what part america is huge
and there's a lot of nature and there's
a lot of like you'll be on road trips
and all of a sudden
it's like a house and i always wonder
before the days of
amazon before the days of any of that
[ __ ] how do they get their groceries
and then sometimes it's in the desert so
you're like you know they're not growing
[ __ ]
yeah the [ __ ] are they eating cactus and
goat dick
like can beans dehydrated goat dick
though
so it lasts a little jerky and rock like
what are they eating i'm so curious
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you